a win is a win the cowboys absolutely
stink so you beat the cowboys in a windy
game carson wentz what's the state of
the union right now there in philly
he's he said that he um he's going to
continue to be aggressive didn't he say
that
i think you said that yeah i heard that
yeah and for god to want to continue to
be aggressive with all those turnovers
i'm looking at him like are you sure you
want to continue to be aggressive i just
think you know i look at the guy and
he's got some talent i just
he's just not very good he's just not
consistent what makes a quarterback good
is consistency and he just doesn't give
you that i
quite frankly i don't i don't really
know what they see in a guy i mean i
know he's a big guy and at times you
look and say you know what that's the
carson wentz that i've been waiting for
and then all of a sudden you look and
say how the heck they gave him a 100
million dollar contract i wouldn't give
him a 20 million dollar contract so it's
just his inconsistency that really
bothers me um jack
that's interesting rodney have you
always felt like they probably shouldn't
have paid him have you felt in the past
like they should have kept fools around
or have you felt that they need to look
in a completely different direction from
the quarterback room that they've had
over these last few years
well since they drafted carson um in the
first round i figured you know
eventually nick foles would move on and
go and get paid like he did and you know
carson wentz would have an opportunity
but it's just what i see you know and as
much as the injuries i know we had a
bunch of offensive alignment and things
like that
but they have capable guys on the
outside even if they're young guys these
guys have played well
but i look at carson man and he just he
talks about big plays and it just seems
like he wants the big play all the time
and i just don't see a level of patience
and then last year what was the
complaint or the end of the year before
oh he only throws to tight ends he's
only thrown to tight ends well his tight
ends were hurt at one point now he
started going to the wide receivers
i just looked and i still question
at this point in time why did they pay
him that type of money he's just not
very good
some of these young quarterbacks that
just seem to me like they're doing a
little bit too much and i i think we saw
that from lamar jackson yesterday i
think we've seen that from deshaun
watson all season long and i think we've
seen that from carson wentz way too
often they just hold the ball instead of
two three seconds nothing there floated
out of bounds it's like two three
seconds nothing there instead of going
one two three oh i gotta run and so then
it turns into scramble drill and then it
turns into miracle drill and i'm gonna
create a magical play and then it's an
interception or then it's a sack fumble
and it's something crazy and we keep
seeing it with these young quarterbacks
that have some athleticism i think it's
one of the things that's really got
winston to a lot of trouble
yeah and the thing that i see from wence
is when when great quarterbacks drop
back tom brady knows exactly there's
going to be a curl there's going to be a
dig there's going to be a post and now
he's focused on the defense so he knows
exactly where everybody's at now he can
focus on a defense okay the safety came
down they're either man or they're in
cover three
carson wentz doesn't do that his mind
doesn't process he goes back and he
stares at receivers and
oh and then all of a sudden he's
scrambling and he gets sacked and now
it's a 10-yard loss so he throws it up
it's an interception he has to learn how
to process his information more exactly
what the wide receivers are doing and
exactly what the defense is trying to do
to stop it
and the one thing worth mentioning is it
does it did look like that wind was
howling not only in philly but like
around the country yesterday there was a
bunch of these games where they show a
shot of the flag and it's just like oh
and philly was definitely one of those
so i was a little slow on my quarterback
criticism when you see weather like that
uh well you've seen him the last three
three or four years too bro
for sure no that's that's listen we gave
that one the full picture there i'm
right there with you okay quarterback
wide receiver combo that have had plenty
of success
dk metcalf has looked phenomenal now the
conversation's starting to transition
from this guy's one of the great top 10
wide receivers in the nfl too
might he be the best talking about dk
metcalf well his coach pete carroll
weighed in yesterday after the win
here's what we had to say
he's just so freaking tough and and
whether he's you know whether he's
blocking guys or whether he's catching
the ball or whether you know they smack
him when the ball arrives and and he's
standing over those guys you know when
they fall off of him uh when he caught
the ball on the crossing route i started
screaming that they weren't going to get
him right from like when he was way over
there because he's just too fast and and
uh
he just circled the whole defense and
put the end zone down and i think they
touched him it was a great play
we're so lucky to have him and have him
grown and emerging as such a
dominant football player it's really
something
so he's getting pretty plenty of love
and he's earned a lot of that love has
dk metcalf lebron calls him baby braun
yesterday that's some high praise there
rodney as you take a look at the graphic
from uh from from the last few weeks
yeah and i look at i look at dk metcalf
and you see the guy pregame walking
across the field you see how big and how
just intimidating he is but you also i
look and i see on the sideline i see
those dbs looking and seeing and sizing
them up and that's what he uses he uses
intimidation not just physically but he
is a beast like his mindset goes with
his body a lot of times guys have that
body but they don't have that mindset
and he is a tough dude he's big he's
physical and he wants it i mean when you
run down
a safety when you run down somebody and
you give everything 80 90 yards or
whatever he had to run and you catched
him it's heart it's desire it's deep
down inside of you and that's what he
has and i do believe that he's the best
receiver right now in the national
football league
i actually agree
he won a lot of football fans with with
that run run down of buda baker
and just the lack of hesitation i just
thought like you you put that really
well right there around like you see
guys i mean not very many but you see
guys over the years that have that kind
of a body but it's so rare to have the
combination of body and mind and he
proved the mind thing to me when he just
again the second he saw buddha baker
intercept that ball it wasn't like maybe
i can get him maybe i can run him down
from here maybe i can get an angle he
didn't give a hoot he was like i'm
freaking on a b line right now going
right there catching like he just has no
hesitation to his game and he looks the
same way when he catches the ball and
looks to turn up field he always thinks
he's scoring a touchdown and none of
those db's are going to get in the way
of stopping me did the exact same thing
on sunday
and think about the thousands and
thousands of high school college pro
coaches and just coaches around the
country and people that have taken that
clip of him and i've you know been on
social media and so many coaches like
i'm showing my kids this i'm showing my
team that i mean to make a difference on
a stage like that and and and to be that
influential to everybody else because
you're hustling i mean it had to make
them feel good because that's something
that i showed my son i said hey man come
over here you got to look at this i mean
look at that effort this doesn't take
you don't have to be you know
big fast and strong but it's the effort
it's you digging down deep trying to
make a play and dk metcalf is that guy
man i'm happy for him
in the way that russell wilson talks
about dk metcalf in comparison to jerry
rice lets you know that not only is he a
great game day player but it sounds like
throughout the week throughout the
course of a practice week he is the
hardest worker in that building and so
that's one more lesson that they can
pass down beneath to college and high
school
as well
one lesson they probably should go
without the chargers yesterday
one of the great collapses that i've
ever watched i mean denver is booing the
whole game drew lock these fans the blue
birds were out all day long it's like
they i think if you had pulled half the
fans they would have been looking for a
new quarterback and then denver comes
all the way back here was chargers head
coach anthony lynn after a very tough
loss of which there have been many this
year
i'm sorry i mean i feel bad i mean that
game today we had it completely under
control and the way we lost the game
today that is unacceptable and i take
full responsibility for that
well rodney how do you hear it how would
you think of the finish there as the you
just saw a chargers collapse
well anthony lynn is right he has to
take responsibility because his team
played hard
they didn't execute in the final minutes
and it continues to happen to the
charges i mean we've seen this the last
two or three years whether it's a
penalty whether it's a missed field goal
a block punt we've just seen this over
and over and no matter how much talent
they got a young quarterback no matter
how much excitement that goes into being
around you know what you got going you
got to be able to finish those games and
if you can't finish those games that's a
direct reflection to the head coach and
if it's me i'm looking at that tape and
i'm saying this this is happening far
too often guys i'm going to decide to
bench some guys and you gotta make some
personnel changes you have to be able to
send a message and let those guys know
that this is unacceptable if you wanna
be a los angeles charger you gotta learn
how to finish and this is something that
we're not gonna do
with justin herbert do you get the
feeling like and i understand that they
haven't won yet and but it's a little
bit of the same situation with the
bengals like when you're playing that
young of a quarterback where there's a
little learning curve there about
learning how to win
for three quarters for three and a half
quarters do you get the sense that the
chargers are a good football team like
is it a football team the foundation of
this program is it heading in the right
direction or is this one that's going a
little different direction than you
mentioned you felt the bengals were
that's an excellent question and i i do
believe they're heading in the right
direction a lot of times you got to go
through some tough times in order to get
to the really good times and you know
this is a team that they have a lot of
talent offensively i think mike williams
is one of the top five or sixes
receivers in national football league i
mean he's that good um keenan allen and
the running backs i know um
austin eckler he got hurt hunter henry i
mean they have the foundation they went
out and drafted kenneth murray
um linebacker who i think is fantastic
you get durian james back possibly next
year hopefully he can stay healthy for
an entire year they have the foundation
rashad
jenkins the free safety they have talent
on both sides of the ball but now it's
time for anthony lynn
with this young quarterback to
incorporate everything and start to
finish i like anthony lynn as a coach i
like his demeanor i like what he brings
and how he deals with his players he
just has to
just they just have to finish that's all
for sure the derwent james andrew was
just a crusher
coming into the season just an absolute
crushing injury for that defense
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports